[Music]
welcome to another episode of vm
end-to-end a show where we have a vm
skeptic and a vm enthusiast come
together to hash out all things google
cloud vm related brian thanks again for
coming i'm excited for this episode
money matters to everybody
yeah
exactly last episode we said we're going
to have to talk about cost what this is
going to do to my pockets and and that's
what i want to know because before this
episode i actually went and filled out a
spreadsheet i listed all of my resources
all of my machines the cpus
and and and then i went and saw how much
it would cost to just put that over in
the cloud yeah and i know this is i
don't know if you're gonna be surprised
by this it was way more expensive than
just running it on prem what's up with
that that does happen when you do kind
of a straight one-to-one mapping
sometimes um and i think the
the key thing is where cloud usually
saves the most money is
through having high utilization of what
you're of the machines you're actually
running at the time and changing what
you're running over time so my question
back to you is
how did you decide on those machine
sizes to put into the spreadsheet and do
the math out from i i will be honest i
sized it based on if i was purchasing
purchasing a machine today i would need
it to last three to five years so
how much ram do i need to have for it to
be still relevant three to five years
from now how much space and then also i
need these machines to be able to handle
uh peak workloads that i might not
always be operating at and so i had to
be able to have cpu and ram that could
handle the worst case scenario so most
days they're probably way overspecified
and then
occasionally they're you know kind of
hitting their their limits
um
and that's yes but they were cheaper
than
the cloud like you know what i mean they
were cheaper than the cloud vms that's
where you know the bulk of the savings
and i think there's some other stuff i
want to hit but the bulk of the savings
come from this kind of pay for what you
use
kind of concept and you won't
pay for what you use i i hear this i
hear this all the time and i and i don't
quite understand it
i i just interrupted and you were going
to explain it but i just hear this
phrase so much and i'm like so i really
want to know so the simplest is you know
like you turn the machines off and
you're not using them but
i think it also is a little bit
confusing because usage is kind of a
broad term and we use it for actually
two different kind of concepts in google
cloud there's the
pay for specific work done so like if
you're using a cloud storage bucket like
actually saving an item in the bucket or
retrieving it
and then there's this kind of sense of
reservations so the way most the billing
for the vm works is it starts when you
make the ap i call to turn it on and
when you call it turn it off that's when
the billing stops so it's this kind of
reservation so when they talk down to
the second pay for what you use that's
what they're saying and that's okay yeah
and we actually do build to the second
with a 10-minute minimum the so when you
do the math out for a way overspecified
machine it's gonna sit at like five
percent usage or something all the time
and all that extra is wasted um and
that's what we want to avoid to you know
save the most money the other thing
though
that does make a lot of sense i'm going
to
jump on a little bit so when you just do
the spreadsheet out
you're only focusing on the the
computers right
and
there's a lot more to it yeah you know
so you know you you have people's time
to set those up to troubleshoot them
when something goes wrong to respond to
failures that might happen you may be
over buy for redundancy you've got to
hook them up to a network you probably
have some security boundaries you want
to enforce maybe you buy a load balancer
all this kind of extra stuff that is
actually baked into the cost you know at
the hourly kind of or like the per
second kind of rate of a cloud vm yeah
that really does add up over time and
okay and that that's true like if i had
to factor in people hours and all the
rest of this those costs in my
spreadsheet would go way up
something i am concerned with though
because it seems like a cloud vm is
a different mental paradigm it's a shift
in how we have to think about it so what
are the hidden costs or gotchas that
come up when people are switching from
on-prem and like a lot of moving parts
and like we're encouraging you to turn
things on and off and maybe run test
environments and other stuff
um you hear stories about like i've got
this charge running on some other
service that i know where it comes from
um that i think we've got a pretty good
solution for in google cloud so we have
a concept of a project and all of the
resources live in this project and so if
you if you delete the project all the
resources will get turned off and not
charged for in the future
so
hi i want something like that for all of
my random subscriptions in life
um that would be amazing
there are some kind of not obvious
uh
things that i think are worth paying for
or that you know you might not think to
include in your in your estimates um
so the the worth it side i think it's
worth looking into the support options
because there's some
some really
highly trained really awesome folks on
our support team who can help you out
when things get into troubleshooting
mode um so i think that's worth thinking
about the other one that i i think is
really can be a surprise is network
traffic so
inbound networking is all free and kind
of part of the deal but you do pay for
out going out of the cloud what we call
egress a bandwidth and it's different
depending on where it goes oh so like
different zones might cost more uh or
from one zone to another so crossing
regions you know um cost a little bit of
money not as much and then getting out
of cloud entirely like so if you if
you've got traffic going to the united
states or to asia or europe there's a
slightly different rate for each
it seems like there's a lot of different
moving pieces and parts you touched on
that earlier
how do i actually go about estimating
what it's going to cost for me or how
much of you know machine type 1 i'm
going to need in machine type 2
different tiers of service how do you go
about estimating that i have to
unfortunately admit this is actually
kind of hard to do
partly because there are so many moving
pieces and you know like a straight up
multiply it out in a spreadsheet is way
overestimate so how do we get more
accurate um
one of the things we can do if you've
got a really good understanding of a
workload we have an online calculator
that includes all of our discounts and
all the different services and you can
kind of fill it all in
and you'll get a solid estimate of what
that would cost
unfortunately
it's kind of difficult to get to that
level of knowledge of a system without
running the system um and so
what
you know what tends to be the most
accurate is to run a mini version of the
system
and
log and monitor that and you know kind
of do a spike you know for either a
shorter amount of time or with fewer
machines just to see what is actually
all of the moving pieces and then you
can use that as a base to multiply and
estimate from
that actually makes a lot of sense
um
i guess one thing i'm curious about
though because it makes sense that uh if
i'm only spinning up machines that i'm
mostly utilizing i'm going to save money
in that way what about if i
have
machines that are running for a long
time though or if i'm close to
utilization because it seems like this
is a rental type model where i'm renting
renting renting and never really owning
are there any kind of services there's a
whole bunch um
and i i think the the main thing is
um and this is this is you know you're a
kubernetes guy like why do containers
exist at all like
i think it's to try to get high
utilization on the host machine so that
you get the most work
you know and the container keeps each
app in its own space so you can put a
lot of different things in the same box
and run the box you know at 80 instead
of five
things like that so
we have an extra tool in cloud vms where
you can instead of trying to fit a lot
of pieces in one box you can change the
shape of the box
so
you if you have a workload that is very
ram and intensive or very cpu intensive
you can change the shape of the machine
to fit your actual process
i actually like that a lot uh
i'm gonna throw in a random example but
if i was packing a backpack it's like if
i can change the shape of the dividers i
can fit more in instead of trying to
find odd shaped items to fit into the
backpack so that's kind of one of the
benefits you get in the cloud and that
still lets you pay less because again
you're utilizing less space and those
shapes that make sense yeah that doesn't
really
well i was gonna say that doesn't really
touch on the yeah okay so kind of model
like uh this idea that we're paying a
lot but we're never really owning to
kind of address that more directly um
you know it is always going to be a
rental but you know when you're using it
for a long time it's more efficient and
so we automatically offer what we call a
sustained use discount when that uh is
the case so if you're running the same
kinds of cpus doesn't even need to be
the same machine the same kinds of cpu
over time will automatically give you a
discount of up to like around 30
and then if you know
so there's a big deal there and then if
you know you've got that kind of base
workload over a long period of time you
can essentially kind of reserve that a
committed use discount to pay ahead and
get an even bigger discount on that okay
so there's a lot of savings there
there was another one i did a quick scan
i did a quick look in and this one blew
my mind i do not understand that at all
they were called preemptable vms can you
tell me about those so if you imagine
you know we were talking about this
tetris problem trying to fit things in
you've got a data scanner data center
scale version of that
um and so
if we can uh run machines in the corners
it's useful um so
but we need to stay flexible so we we
offer a machine preemptable type or like
a preemptable mode basically
that fits in there so if you
know that you have a workload that is
either relatively quick or that can be
restarted you can run it there and run
it at like a fifth of the cost a fifth
of the cost 20 of the cost so the only
difference between a preemptable and a
regular machine is that it's guaranteed
never to last more than 24 hours it will
stop and it might turn off at any moment
so you have to be able to kind of
restart your work okay but for
for the types of workloads that would
fit for that's a huge savings i guess
another thing i'm really interested in
is on that is on that model
again i'm used to
maybe use using five percent and now
we're moving towards using eighty
percent
um
what happens if i'm not using anything
at all for a little while or like you
know i don't actually have any activity
going on you know even better so if you
if you stop a vm
you don't you only pay for the disk
usage and nothing for the actual cpu
memory uh part of it so you can stop it
and then turn it back on whenever you
want
and you can even do that on a schedule
so if you know like three days a month
this machine needs to be working you can
schedule that ahead of time oh wow okay
then what about for things that i don't
like like i can't predict per se
a spike in traffic for some sale or
something that went on some celebrity
mentioned my product
is there any way to have the most common
pattern there i think is
groups of machines that are running kind
of the same image that work together and
all live behind a load balancer so
you've got traffic coming into one place
and gets kind of spread across a couple
of computers and then you get more
traffic and you add a few more computers
less traffic you you turn them off so
the the manage instance group can
actually auto scale the size of the
group based on load or metrics that you
define and again you're only paying once
those vms start up they're on and they
exist
wow okay so to recap because this
actually seems really cool and it's
changed the way i think about
uh pricing and cost because before i was
buying for the next five years or so
plus playing for people to manage things
i was paying for networking and all the
rest of that and now with the cloud it
seems like you're really running or
buying for the next five seconds or so
what am i using right now okay let me
try to only pay for that i agree 100
does that sound like a good rico okay
so then
you know what i kind of want to go and i
actually try this out i want to take my
spreadsheet and i want to go and
in based on the different types of work
i want to see what discounts i can get
uh any any tips or like next steps that
i should take yeah i mean yes go do that
start some vms and see how they work um
but i want to let you know there's
actually um a free trial and a free tier
to help you do that and experiment with
cloud so a trial and a tier uh please
explain so it's a little confusing
they're both t's and they put like free
trial free tier um so everyone new to
google cloud gets a 300 coupon basically
to use in 90 days for any service any
part of cloud they want to use it on
and in addition to that there's a long
running tier so the first little bit of
usage for about 20 different products
is free and then only after that do we
charge and included in that is a small
vm that you can leave running
as long as you want oh wow all right
that is really cool uh
i'm gonna have to go and check some of
this out brian thank you so much for
coming in if you're listening at home uh
step number one is go try out the free
tier or the free trial and anyone else
if you've been using google cloud for a
while
if you know about pricing and cost share
some tips in the comment below for other
folks that maybe aren't as experienced
i'll go through and read that i think
that'd be really helpful thanks for
watching and thank you again brian
[Music]
you